yeah john means will try to win for the
sixth time on his first four decisions
of the year you know everybody talks
about the uh
the no hitter and why not up in seattle
on the fifth of may but if you go back
to opening day the second uh his first
game against the red sox one hitter
for seven innings and we saw kind of a
precursor to uh what was really going to
go on as far as his stuff
so he just needs to you know if you've
got to throw a home run make them solos
he does throw home runs 22 of them
and uh you know just make sure nobody's
on the last game
gave up two home runs one was a three
run home run and one was a two run home
run cruz hit the three runner and then
we're ready to go john means
and albies puts it in the air shallow
center cedric mullins racing in calls
and makes the grab
had to go a long way in short center
field albie's out number one here's
jorge solaire right-handed batter facing
means eight straight wins for the braves
and down on strikes so there john means
first track out of the game two down so
plus velocity you know average fastball
is about a mile per hour slower than
last year but if you make quality
pitches low and away you get a really
good chance of being successful hitters
eyes up eyes down here's freeman first
pitch swinging sound like a broken bat
he'll have to flip the means
for the tag and it's a one two three
start nice start for john means as the
braves go in order and it's tookie
toussaint on the mound for the braves
coming off a win against the marlins he
got a lot of run support and made those
runs stand up jeff with six in the third
innings of real good work yeah not only
that tuki has been outstanding on the
road this year so far 2.41 era with uh
four watts to 20 caves
and mullins hitless in the series flies
out on his first pitch of the day
and adam duvall makes short work of
cedric mullins one up one down so
mancini at 20 homer man it's worth
repeating the pitch on the ground dan's
beat ozzy for one and the flip to first
in time a double play there's that
ground ball work from tuki toussaint
orioles are doubled up and we had to
escort a second austin reilly two balls
and no strikes and
high pop up right side mount castle
going over to the extended warning track
makes the catch on the grass
for the first outs of the second inning
dansby swanson one down in the brave
second
he swings and sky's this one shallow
right mount castle out ooh sante and air
slides right behind then he catches him
yep yep
just slid under him a little wet spot on
the pants there for ryan mycastle but
important thing they got the out
everybody's okay two down it's almost
like a soccer match the red card oh and
he catches him grass a little wet we had
some rain prior to the game well let's
see from santanders 26 he catches the
younger oriole in his arms the baby bird
so to speak malcolm's only 24. this is
adam duvall two strike pitch another
pop-up
let's see if mount castle could get
three this inning there you go he's got
it so ryan modcastle with three pop-ups
handles them all
no score bottom of the third of the
one-two on the way struck him out
second strikeout martin's over seven in
the series and this is what you don't
want you don't want runners on with
their two three four hitters coming up
on the ground ozzy gets there fields
flips to first close play they got him
and that will
retire the side big play by ozzy albees
catcher running saved the braves in the
third one out for jorge soler frames
haven't done much with john means yet 39
pitches in the fourth inning
high fly ball did solaire get enough to
the warning track to the wall stuart
leaps he can't get it solaire has put
the braves in front with a solo home run
that's what means gives up that's what
the braves do they score first it's one
nothing in the fourth inning watch out
for duvall his best work has come with
runners at second or third base this
year pitch
swing and a shot hammered toward left
center field mullins on the run can't
get it braves will add on freeman scores
here comes swanson around third they're
gonna bring him home dew fall with a
double
it's three-nothing atlanta they walk
swanson to get to adam and he made him
pay so it will take a two out base hit
to get the orioles on the board here the
two
right side that's a fair ball
so arias into the right field corner
going for two here comes the throw and
he's in with an rbi double orioles on
the board it's 3-1 well bookend doubles
you kind of like that graves on top of
the orioles 3-1 as we head into the
fifth inning means delivers breaking
ball bounced to short martin up with it
one down
works from the third base out of the
rubber 3-1 braves with the lead here it
comes here's a wave down goes
peterson
not number two
down goes peterson really good slider
yeah watch his rear end trying to stay
in there just couldn't quite keep it in
there third strikeout for john means two
down and here's ozzy albee's and there's
another one
albee's down on strikes impressive
inning two strikeouts means gets him one
two three dylan tate comes in came in on
friday night got some big outs the
braves have two on with nobody down
little chopper that'll get the runners
up no they get one and they do turn two
oh williams williams sounds like a
catcher yeah catcher catcher speed helps
yeah i'm thinking gee that's going to be
first and third but they turn it very
nicely there's the sinker and there's
the ground ball six four
three
fourth double play in the game two for
both teams yeah it looks to me matteo
much much more comfortable swanson at
third two down now
radio chops it back to the mound dake
loves it fires to first base and yet
again
nicely done dylan tate and he gets the
braves in the seventh without allowing a
run and pitching out of a major jam that
means it's time for luke jackson he will
follow
minter
martin and matsik
in relief of tooky toussaint today now
we saw luke last night come in after
matson got mullins two thirds of inning
gave up a couple hits big strikeout to
end the threat luke's done good work and
the 2-2 from luke jackson
fastball froze him he wasn't expecting
that perfectly placed pitch in jackson's
eighth inning off to a great start one
out line after three sliders in a row
dots him up 96 right on the inner half
santander is the hitter switch hitter
flips around left-handed swing and a
miss disappearing slider jackson came
back to get his man two strikeouts in
the eighth inning so righty righty now
for jackson austin hayes stands in the
way of sending us to the ninth inning
with a lead of three to one
struck out the side he got him with two
fastballs
mancini and hayes caught looking and
that ends the bottom of the eighth great
job by luke jackson so franco stands in
the way of will smith two balls two
strikes two down
he got him it's a perfect road trip
atlanta beats the birds 3-1 is your
final score will smith saves it for tuki
toussaint and the braves sweep
you